el crimen ha conmocionado a los sectores
más próximos al gobierno no hay que
olvidar que el padre de daria doguín a
alexander du quien está considerado como
el principal ideólogo de la revolución
conservadora que ha apuntalado a
vladimir putin en el cree mientras su
regreso a la presidencia en el año
2012 desde el gobierno ruso ya se están
buscando culpables y la propia portavoz
del ministerio de asuntos exteriores de
rusia maría sájarov ha dicho que hay que
buscar la pista ucraniana en este
atentado ocurrido anoche y que si de
hecho eso se confirmase que están los
ucranianos detrás de la muerte de daria
dubina entonces habría que señalar
definitivamente a ucrania como un estado
terrorista es conocido que tanto doguín
como daria divina tenían enemigos
precisamente por sus posiciones muy
firmes a favor de una injerencia rusa en
ucrania para apuntalar
imperialismo ruso y la predominancia de
moscú en los viejos territorios del aus